welcome to Table Talk episode number 8
my name is Brett pastor at the table and
today I want to talk about why although
the Bible is a bit weird and many points
drives me crazy I continue to love it
but before I get to exactly that let me
back up a bit and put some framework
around this so the Bible is the big
story through which I make sense of all
other stories including my own story
what do I mean
well the philosopher Martin Heidegger
said that to be human is to find
ourselves thrown into the world's what
he means is that it can be really
disorienting to be human because we're
born in the world with certain duties
and frustrations and sufferings and it
all just happens to us no one asks us so
would you like to be born we simply grow
up and find ourselves living and because
of this it's essential that we find our
bearings so to speak right that we find
a a bigger broader story to make sense
of our individual stories but be warned
choose your story with care so you think
about it some of the most powerful and
destructive social movements in the
world are powerful precisely because
they become a story that others believe
in mass right think of for example
communism it's a story story about class
warfare it's a certain reading of
history with problems and solutions and
it has heroes and villains and ethics a
way of living or think of the fascist
movement Nazism again it's a story a
story about history about the fatherland
about blood and soil and who the good
people are the bad people are it's a
story and I might add that both the
Communists and Nazis stories turned out
to be incredibly dangerous stories right
if you think about it really all
politics and all religions are stories
heck even science and technology when
elevated to the level of a belief system
something we rely on to tell us what
the good is what the true is how to live
what to orient our lives around it
really becomes a story a big story about
how we as objective human beings using
nothing but sheer logic and clear
thinking are marching onwards and
upwards towards a glorious future notice
there's a certain like moral element to
that it has a narrative arc to it right
it's a story okay so why do I love the
Bible and why I love the Christians
story and specifically the Jesus story
well some of you may know a bit about my
own history about ten years ago I was in
a season where I was doubting the truth
in beauty of the Christian story see I'd
read enough of the Bible to know that
the way God is described at points again
not the whole thing but at points is
let's just say less than stellar but I
gained a tremendous clarity as I read
the atheist philosopher Friedrich
Nietzsche when he wrote in his book the
antichrist that Christianity at its
heart
he said it's it's an ethic an impulse
it's a love of all things lowly and
despised which is why I Nietzsche wrote
and here I'm quoting he said God on the
cross are the horrible secret thoughts
behind this symbol not yet understood
all that suffers all that is nailed to
the cross is divine infer nichy this was
about the worst thing ever
why well he found it to be a monstrous
story but for me it was different I
realized this is exactly what I loved
about Christ and Christian of faith and
this is why I love the Bible because
it's largely written from the
perspective of the despised and weak and
suffering and think about it it
culminates in the story of a crucified
God who is raised from the dead as a
final powerful statement that sheer
power
and violence does not have the final
word mercy in grace and suffering love
has the final word
that's a beautiful compelling story and
it's a story through which I now read
and interpret in my own life and the
world around me right it's it's less
something I stand back from and
objectively evaluate and it's more like
the grid through which I evaluate other
things I evaluate my politics and others
politics through the lens of that story
evaluate my church and other churches
through that story I evaluate my life
and other's lives through that story so
this is why I love the Bible for all its
weirdness it is a beautiful story and
it's one I am choosing to live by no you
may say well yes but what about the
truth don't you believe the Bible is
true and like don't you have rational
arguments for why you believe in God the
Bible of Jesus resurrection etc sure
right truth matters and I'll get to
those things in future talks my point is
simply that the beauty of the Christian
story is a key reason it has been
persuasive for millions of people around
the world well that's all for today if
you like this video please like and
share it and subscribe to my youtube
channel by searching Brett Tilford so
you don't miss any future episodes Grace
and peace